los viajes respetuosos con el medio
ambiente se aceleran y es alemania la
que lidera el camino con la primera
línea ferroviaria que funciona
totalmente con hidrógeno francia también
ha desempeñado un papel la flota de 14
trenes ha sido fabricada por la empresa
francesa alstom estoy extremadamente
satisfecho
extremadamente feliz con este estreno
mundial porque este es el primer tren de
producción en serie que está siendo
utilizado todos los días por los
pasajeros y creo que va a cambiar
completamente la forma que vemos los
trenes y en particular va a abrir y
allanar el camino para una
transformación completa de todos los
trenes diésel en trenes electrificados
de hidrógeno se dice que los trenes de
hidrógeno son los más ecológicos que
existen ya que la emisión de los gases
de escape es agua pura la nueva flota
que ha costado 93 millones de euros
evitará la emisión de 4.400 toneladas de
co2 al año según el operador de esta red
podemos convertirnos y nos convertiremos
en el estado con mayor cantidad de
energía de toda alemania no sólo en lo
que se refiere a la producción de
energía renovable sino sobre todo a su
uso de forma inteligente es una
expansión el próximo destino de los
trenes será frankfurt también harán una
parada en italia y francia donde alstom
ha firmado contratos para fabricar
varias docenas de trenes